je dois passer le plein de messages sur
les réseaux sociaux à propos des
chemtrails c'est rémy blanche qu'on voit
dans le ciel des raisonnements qu'est ce
que c'est
[Applaudissements]
ça lui aurait dit salut sherin les kent
wells c'est l'une des théories du
complot les plus populaires en france
chez les 18 24 ans on aurait un jeune
sur trois qui croiraient et donc c'est
quoi cette rennaise marche c'est de la
condensation dans l'air qui se forment
au passage des réacteurs de l'avion on
appelle en anglais des coachs wells
littéralement des traînées de
condensation
mais les conspirationnistes eux
appellent ça des chemtrails ce qu'est la
contraction de camille coltrane ce parce
qu'il pense qu'il s'agit d'épandage de
produits chimiques c'est quoi les noms
sont les complotistes s'est produit
serait destiné à nous empoisonner pour
nous éliminer la théorie dit kent wells
rejoint une théorie plus large celle
d'un plan secret de réduction de la
population mondiale un plan où les
riches les puissants voudrait éliminer
les pauvres mais d'autres conspuent
pense que les chemtrails sont un plan de
l'otan pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
en modifiant la météo secrètement
d'autres disent que on ne sait pas ce
qu'il ya dans ces produits chimiques
mais qui sont à l'origine de maladies
comme alzheimer ou parkinson
mais comment on peut être sûr que c'est
faux sur les réseaux sociaux on voit
même des photos avec des avions équipés
de produits dans l'arche haute en fait
ces photographies sont complètement
sortis leurs comptes avec les cuves que
tu voies sont des ballasts destiné à
simuler des charges dans des avions en
phase de test d'autres photos
représentent des produits destinés à
lutter contre les marées noires et
l'avion qui déverse une traînée blanche
et la version américaine de canadair il
sert à lutter contre les incendies on
voit aussi ses photos de traces blanches
dans les champs alors ces filaments
blancs bien connu des gens qui habitent
à la campagne en fait ce sont des fils
de soie qui permettent la migration des
jeunes araignée qui cette du vent pour
se disperser dans la nature à l'automne
pour les conspirationnistes sont des
traces chimiques mais pour les raéliens
les membres de la secte de raël ce sont
des traces d'un passage de soucoupe
volante liées à l'apparition de la
vierge marie donc on voit qu'on peut
raconter tout et n'importe quoi sur ces
fameuses traînées blanches mais qui
diffuse sa ces images ont été détournés
pendant la pandémie par des gens opposés
aux mesures sanitaires ils prétendent
que l' oms diffusé le virus avec ovi de
19 par épandage nous tuer ils disent
aussi que plusieurs pays la pologne la
suède la norvège aurait déposé une
plainte contre l'om est il assure même
que les pilotes ont été arrêtés et
qu'ils ont avoué tout ça est évidemment
complètement faux mais c'est quoi le but
le but c'est de mettre en doute une
forme de vérité officielle les cannoises
sont un exemple parfait des mécanismes
intellectuels à l'oeuvre dans les
théories conspirationnistes
ils permettent d'entretenir l'idée qu'on
nous ment et de créer une peur presque
paranoïaque face aux puissants quitte à
produire des fausses preuves or la peur
est la meilleure alliée de la
manipulation manipule plus facilement
quelqu'un à qui on fait croire que le
monde entier conspirent contre nice
aussi simple que ça
[Musique]